okay here's Andy who's five foot six so
he's vertically challenged but a very
very handsome guy who is doing some
things right and a lot of things wrong
and if I look at his before picture
remember the day he came into the
magazine he had that kind of side swept
hair very very handsome face probably a
little bit too much facial hair but then
there was that tie there was much too
wide and that shirt that was much too
big and that belt buckle that was much
too big so for someone with a smaller
frame all over the proportions were too
big even the collar on his shirt was too
big under five foot seven you're
considered a short so you need to buy a
short so he is a 44 short and it's very
important that he recognizes that and he
goes to people who have that in that in
this case it's Brooklyn tailors but you
could also get it from suit supply Ralph
Lauren Isle Stewart even Jay crew does
short so there's a lot of people out
there that make shorts we put him in
this really vibrant blue suit now not
peacock blue but like a much more
heightened navy blue and put him with a
striped shirt a polka dot tie and really
made his look noticeable just because
you're a little bit vertically
challenged we don't want you to go
unnoticed so we've got this beautiful
blue suit and then because he's an
architect we gave him suede shoes
because he doesn't work in a law firm he
doesn't have to be you know completely
buttoned up we took a lot of his facial
hair down because we just thought it was
it was making him look smaller somehow
and we wanted to see more of his face
and then we took a great head of hair
and made it even better and snipped the
sides and gave him a little height on
top which gave him a little bit more a
height advantage and I think in the end
were really happy with it and I know
he's happy with it too and he's going to
wear a suit every day to work so he said